こんにちははじめしゃちょーです見覚えが
ある方もいらっしゃるのではないでしょう
か私はじめ社長が住んでいた前のお家で
ございますちょっと前の動画で前のおうち
の退去にいくらになったのっていう動画を
出したと思うんですけどもそれこっちの家
です1号室と2号室借りてて2号室の方は
あの動画のタイミングで退去してたんです
けども今回こちらの僕が確か大学3年の時
かな大学3年の時に引っ越して今日まで8
年間
借りましたこの1号室の方
今日持って
退去することになりました
うんちょっと
切ないですねさすがに僕のメイン
チャンネル昔から見てくださってる方だっ
たらもう最初はこの家でめっちゃ暴れてて
畑ができてからこっちの家に移動したので
もう本当の初期の初期はこの家でずっと
動画撮ってたんですよ僕YouTuber
になって今11年目なんですけど8年借り
てるのでもう半分以上はこの家で動画撮っ
てるのは間違いないと思います逆になんで
今まで借りてたのかと4億円のうち買った
のになんではじめさんまだこんなに借り
てるんだと手放したくなかったからなん
ですいい家そしていい大家さん素晴らしい
環境全てが整っててなぜか手放さずに
ずっと撮ってたっていうお家なんですけど
使わないお家をずっと借りてるぐらいだっ
たら別の人に使っていただいた方がいいし
[音楽]
退去費あのですね
ボロボロなんですよもう本当に申し訳ない
んですけども8年間YouTuberが
住んで僕一人ではなく畑はじめ社長の畑も
途中から使ってて大人数でもうわちゃわ
ちゃしててボロボロなんですよ2号室の
退去費とかもう多分日にならないくらい
ボロボロなのでいい感じしてる人がその
なんとなくの退去費のなんか
計算はもうできて
るっぽいのでちょっとどれくらいボロボロ
になってるのか見ていきたいと思います
懐かしいもう
この3階建ての家
今日でラストよ完全にこれ
賃貸だと思わないよね家賃15万円なん
ですよで
駐車場のガレージ付きでしょここ登るのも
これで最後ここもいろんな動画撮りました
ね
懐かしいなぁストーカーが来てから監視
カメラつくようになりましたね着きました
家の真ん前です
ちょい前退去したのはこっちの家で1号室
のここ
で退去しますそうですね
懐かしみながらというのもあるんですけど
どっちかというとどれだけボロボロなのか
8年間わんぱくYouTuber住んだら
家どうなっちゃうのかっていうのをお見せ
できればなと思っておりますでは行き
ましょう
失礼します
[音楽]
懐かしいうわ
懐かしい
でも前の家とほぼ作り一緒だからあんまり
違いないのとどっちかというとはじめて畑
の方でしばらく使ってたからそっちの記憶
の方が多いんだよなあーでもこの部屋とか
あれで使いましたねなんかオレンジの洗剤
かけると風船割れるみたいなやつとかもう
この部屋でやりましたね
あれなんでなんでだなんちょっとなんでな
ネットの記事で割れるって書いてあったの
に
ごめんなさいその記憶がめっちゃ強い
こういう汚れとかありますねこの部屋はね
比較的
[音楽]
なかなか普通の使い方してるけどこんな
破り方しねえよな所々やっぱちょっと
傷がついてますねなんか待ってててるし
もうね中のものは全部出して清掃入ったり
とかどこが壊れてどこが補修しなきゃいけ
ないのかとかももう見られ始めててなんか
汁とか貼ってるんですよこれとかね両面で
絶対これも取り替えじゃん
でも
意外ときれいには使ってる気はするけどな
ここはいやこうやって見ると玄関とか
めっちゃ汚いんだよなぁ8年使うとこう
なっちゃうのか
[音楽]
謎のあと発見なんか引きずったんだろうな
懐かしいですねこの部屋とかも結構俺は
懐かしいなぁ
壊れてる
スイッチがないこれ俺じゃないですからね
俺じゃないこれは俺こんなことやった記憶
ないこの部屋はね昔より
がして動画に出た
運動会の
起こしてやるみたいなやつそれここでやっ
たんですよ
[音楽]
1について用意
早く早く早く
懐かしいなここは寝室とか遊戯王カードと
かした時に使ってたお部屋ですね物がもう
何にもないです
[音楽]
これぐらいの汚れたら
でもすごいなんかボコボコだないやー
ちょっともうすごい頑張ってパートだこれ
は俺ですなんか張り紙してた記憶がある
エアコンの中になんでこんな鳥の羽がある
んだユーチューバーするとこういうことに
なっちゃうんだよなぁトイレ見てみよう
失礼します
[音楽]
汚い洗面所
廃墟やこれはやばいなぁ
汚れがすごいです
意外とこういうのは綺麗お風呂場も実は
そんな汚いですね
これこれは多分
浴槽全開ですね
暴れすぎましたじゃあ次3が行ってみたい
と思います
[音楽]
穴開いてるな俺じゃないよこれは俺じゃ
ないこれ
誰がやったんだこれ俺じゃないよね
後輩さんじゃないですか
これはねやりすぎだねこれもなんか絶対
なんか引きずってたでしょこれ
[音楽]
ソファーとか運んだ時なのか
なやばいすごい
[音楽]
床が取れてるしなんか絶対落ちちゃいけ
ない液体が落ちてるここも剥がれてるこの
境目の子供もボロボロですねそしてここが
一番よく使ってた部屋ですね
ここのイメージはありますねこれがここに
住んでた時はここ一番よく使ってました
なんかこういう感じのサムネでここになん
か机があってなんか引っ越しましたみたい
な感じやった記憶があるなあれからもう8
年ですよきっと当時動画見てたみんなも年
取ったし私ももう年をとりました
元気ですけどねちょっと見ていきましょう
いやもうねここら辺のボロボロに関しては
ね俺じゃない可能性がかなり高いいや
もちろん俺のもあるけど畑が主に使ってた
んですよここで
わかるかな床とか
凹んでるのよねの所々
すごい
[音楽]
凹んでるここ全開だね
絶対これ全部張り替えたもん
誰だよハッピーパーツではじめ2018年
の2月145年前だねハッピーバースデー
初めて俺じゃないのよ誰かがここで書い
ときましたね冷蔵庫置いてあった場所は
もう終わりだ
[音楽]
キッチンは
いえー僕料理しないので僕ではありません
8年住むとなかなかこういう感じになっ
ちゃうよなならんかまあ一人で住んでた
わけではないからなもう大地君をはじめ
後輩とか畑メンバーとかみんなで途中から
なんか共同生活みたいになってたんで
そりゃあこうなるよね天井のこれを覚えて
ますねこれはバンカーリングだねバンカー
リングでブランコしようとしてた記憶が
あるいきます
321すごいな天井だよこれ皆さん
[音楽]
キモそしてもう一つこの部屋なんか一時期
編集部屋として使ってた気がしますねここ
もねなんか思い出としては
焼きそば食べてて量を減らないドッキリ
ひげ剃り
じゃなくて
難しいな
[音楽]
とか1年間お肉禁止しててなんかこっそり
お肉っぽいけどお肉じゃないの食べる
ドッキリとかやってた記憶がありますね
ここ
そんな部屋だった気がするクローゼット
[音楽]
これはもうダメだやりすぎだってこれは
壁も絶対交換だよ
ね楽しみとかもかなりやばいからこれも
多分前チェンジなんだろうなベランダの
コインはどうなるんだろうここもなんか
やばそうなかなかですねはいというわけで
[音楽]
人と昔住んでいたアップはじめ
アミューズメントパーク1号室を見ました
地下というかガレージのあるんですけど
ちょっとそこにあの実は1個だけどうして
も動かせないことがありましてそれに
関する動画はねちょっと後日近いうちに
あげると思いましたが是非教えてください
[音楽]
売りますはいというわけでここからは
ちょっとあの
謝罪の芋込めて正座させていただきます
いろいろ見て回ったんですけれどもまあ2
号室ほどのねなんかガラス割れてます
バーンとかハチャメチャの測り方はして
ますねちょっと感覚おかしくなってるけど
結構どこらず壁剥がれたり壊れたりしてて
これ多分ね
やばいんですよすでにあの管理会社に見て
いただいて
退去費の予想金額だけも出ておりますので
だいたいこんな値段になるんじゃない
かっていうのはちょっと見ていきたいと
思いますさあ皆さんLINEだと思います
かYouTuberそれも俺だけじゃなく
ていろんなYouTuberで住んで8
年間でこの有様どれくらいの退去費になる
でしょうかじゃあ退去費見させていただき
ますはじめ
社長が8年間住んだ家の退去費
[音楽]
が下がらない前回の
隣の部屋の2号室の退去費が
200万円ほどだったんですけども今回
このお家
362万5,012円
[拍手]
壊したのは僕たちですから
壊したものを直す分に払うお金はもう
仕方ないけど300円
やばいなぁなんか器とか結構出てるんです
けどもどこが一番お金かかってるんだろう
扉がね扉とかのなんか貼り直しとかで結構
お金かかって
またガレージの中塗り直したり3階のあの
やっぱベランダの床とかも全部やり直し
たり
床だね床の張り替え多分ほぼ全部だと思い
ます全張り替えなので床でもかなり良かっ
たかかってますね
床と扉
室内クロスとかまあマジであのー多分限界
価格マジで限界の金額ですねこれ
退去費で360万ってもうそれ相応のこと
知ってきたのはもう自負しております
適正金額かと思われます
お疲れ様です
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
お疲れ様です大家さんはまだ
退去品の
聞いてない聞いたら聞いてないいただき
ました
いただきましたちょっと発表させて
いただきます
ちなみに前回の2号室で覚えてますか
さすがにそうですよね前回ガラスとか割れ
てますから
[音楽]
1号室
待って待って待って待ってはい前回より
34年長いんだよね長いですね
劣化は大谷負担ってのがあるから
100の50を超えるかどうかな
発表します
お値段
見積もりのうつ状態でございます
[音楽]
362万512円
細かくたくさんあるんだガレージと
床全開ですね
買える場所が多いというかそうかホーム
ランの数は少ないけれどもヒットが
たくさんあって買っちゃいました
ありがとうございます
本当にありがとうございました
8年ですね
長いですよ本当に学生時代
からそうですね大学の時から大学3年かな
34年留学してて1年遅かったので3年の
時に来て8年間ずっと済ませていただき
ましたありがとうございますよくうちを
見つけていただきましてありがとうござい
ます2
号室
解約して1号室もずっとお借りしてて
寂しくなりますね本当に
[音楽]
僕の長いYouTuberの歴史
上一番長く住んでた家なので
YouTubeというので
YouTuberという
黎明期だもんねまあそうですね8年前だっ
たらもう当時YouTuberなんてこと
はあんまりなかったもんね
ギリギリない
姿を見れてすごい幸せです
[音楽]
家もすごいなんか
ちょっと変わった家じゃないですか
[音楽]
動画映えもしたし住みやすいしこの大家
さんのお人柄もあってこれはね本当に
恵まれた環境だったなと思ってますもう
少しファンキーな建物にしたかった
建物
大家さんちょっとものの整理に使ってます
けどね
[音楽]
ちょっとまたいわゆる事故物件食べじゃん
いい意味で
[音楽]
本当に
めちゃくちゃ似てすみませんでしたという
気持ちはかなりありまして楽しかったです
よ本当に多少のことではどんなに迷惑かけ
ない
そうですね
それもデカかったです
ね何でもできるんですけど
賃貸って結構わんわん賃貸ってやっぱ
難しいですよねなかなかその建物も
しっかりしないといけないとか近隣住民の
迷惑とかYouTubeの内容にもそう
ですね
最低限のことは守りながらというので
心配しなくて
あれっていう時は必ず相談がありました
そうですね一応やばい時は確認させて
いただいたんですけど結果がこの家の有様
です
本当に8年間ですね
[音楽]
本当にお世話になりましたありがとう
ございましたというわけで大家さん本当に
8年間ありがとうございましたありがとう
ございました